today's match up i'm talking about two
best shooting guards of all times we got
d wade going against james harden
head-to-head only one
will be the one-on-one champion
categories for this episode are
big disrespect bigger disrespect
wild winner which is our surprisingly
great category buzzer beater
and wow factor this episode of one on
one is presented by state farm when it
comes to insurance
you can get the personalized service of
a local agent for a surprisingly great
rate the state park
and to help me figure this out is my
co-host nba veteran
hugh rich what's up baby in the building
man ready to do this
as always hey we got a crazy
legendary special guest for today's
episode this is the nba champion
he's a lock down defender of his
generation amongst many other things
ladies and gentlemen
metal world peace what's up baby
yeah everything's good man keep rich
what's good baby thanks for having me on
the show
yes sir two two good players
and you know i think the only difference
is dua you got a couple of rings you
know
hard is still waiting to get one i'm
hyped bro i'm ready for this so
all right first clip all right d-wade
lays the hammer on kendrick perkins
oh i just got through watching
uh big perk on tv today talking about
god bless his heart and
look at looking look he bless his heart
on that one
you attack big perk like that you know
perk might give you a forearm to your
chest
and that's hard he driving back that was
j j hart he drove and did the spin move
up
yeah it's the spin move for me just to
spin and know you're about to dunk on
somebody's head
he was gone then he said i'll make you
say
l and dude
swearing ew i'm just gonna say ew like
that's nasty
big disrespect big disrespect this
this this is warranted
all right let's let's move on to the
next clip
oh my god oh yeah
i like it because it's draymond
that was a little bit more physicality
involved in it though like
he they kind of hugs in here a little
bit like they kind of watch this
at the end he kind of wrapped his arm
around his race
yeah this was real physical this this is
like one of them dunks that kind of
changed the dynamic of the rest of the
game
like the tension gets a little hot it
gets a little spike
after a dump like this i got d wade that
was just
a all-time great clip right there
definitely
so he came up with the screen spent
somebody could have easily been there
so he already knew he already made his
mind up you guys
and you got perk those are two big dogs
and you know you're going in there he
was going in there for a smoke
so it was just like do you wait for this
one
definitely my opinion all right q what
what do you think
what do you think you listen man
the hard the hard play was nasty it was
that was disrespectful like i said
he he hugged him in the air and you see
it was a little
little little back and forth there after
the play but uh you know that was that
like you said he's the defensive player
of the year but man this
the way first of all he drove by harden
on this play
that was hard on the defensive then he
got ibraka on the help
he said let me go ahead and put you in
spin cycle and then
kp big perk big dog i hate to have you
you doing your job though i heard him
speak on
me yeah 100 times he gonna come to jump
in
the way just took it up with two and
then hit another look go go gadget on
with the one hand and
then he talked he put the cherry on top
with a different effect he came with a
it's obvious it's very clear not that my
vote even matters at this point but d
wade of course gets this one he had me
at the spin
move i mean then he had i think we
already went through it i gotta give
this one to d-way this this
by far the stronger highlight uh which
means
d-wave wins the first round of big
disrespect
uh let's flap it out for b-ray
[Music]
our second category the first one was
big disrespect
the second one is bigger disrespect
i'm serious these are two disrespectful
players in general that's why it's a
big disrespect on to bigger district
space they're gonna be a biggest
disrespect i mean what
first up d-wade here we go i hope y'all
didn't forget flash
i i was i would i think i was in this
game i think i was in this game
oh man d-wade is sick
don't forget let's let's remind the
children i was sitting on the bench when
this happened i'm not i got to see the
replay i believe i was upon this team
and walked through he stepped
obviously it got turned up but the
building was electric when this happened
you see the crowd going crazy
that's going to be a hard one to beat
danny
wesley's face is the worst part of it
his reaction when he on the ground
how do you guard games man like that
foot that right foot was tired
that hey hold up brother you right
though the way he paused
and looked at him though
now you gotta run right right that's the
one where you gotta get up and just go
next time you catch the ball just run up
and hit him with the phone
this is the one you dream of man
they can fall and make it he knew he was
gonna make it huh
look at the bench look at the [ __ ]
though
oh my god
the whole stadium had time to all stand
up together
and then there was a little more time
left or harder to stare at him a little
more
before he shot in that moment wesley's
like oh my goodness
uh all the internet dudes about to have
me on the on the internet
all right let's get to the boating club
this is a hard one
this is a hard one both are very very
disrespectful
meta we're gonna start with you again
between the two clips
who gets the w on this well
the d-wave one obviously was powerful
and that's what every kid want to do
right just dunk on somebody
live i wish i could have done something
like that
amazing but i think the james harden one
that's the ultimate
disrespect when you break somebody's
ankles you didn't quite break his ankles
but he did
come back and hit the shot framed his
ain't cool
going james harden cute i gotta hear
from you
what do you think
this is a tough one man this one was
very close because i mean you gotta
take everything in consideration the way
stepped over him ai style at the end of
it went you know
it was over the seven footer um
but i'm with ron ryan man this one this
one by the
heart the man the man
made him crumble to the ground all right
i didn't already pop out
you and broke you down but after i broke
you down
i took a pause like you don't say this
is how much swag and confidence i got
before i even take the shot
i'ma look at you like yeah i just did
you like that then i'm gonna i'm
about to vomit and being really like
look at look at the bench everything
into it makes it just this was more
disrespectful
in your own building your family in the
crowd
like this ain't cool this is not all
right
i got hard look at that just look at the
imagery right there just look at the
carnage being left
yeah i don't have anything to say more
than what you guys just said
toss it to you again cute because i
wasn't sure but i know for certain
that we got to give this man the bigger
disrespect uh category i mean
like you said it's the eye contact for
me he stopped and
looked at me dead in his eyes he picked
for his shot
and then he delivered on it so that's
disrespectful that's disrespectful
this all right the next category is wild
winner which is our surprisingly great
category this is when a play looks like
it's
not going so well but then ends up being
surprisingly great
oh my god oh my god oh my god that is
that is the definition of a wild winner
and what was dope about this this is
when he returned
back this is after he had the chicago
cleveland whatever that phase hiatus was
and then he came
back and this was braided d-wade this is
braided
i remember watching this game and going
crazy watching this game
that's a great feeling to hit our game
winner man that's and it's like a
throw-up
that is the definition of a wild wild
finish
y'all the basketball gods were on his
side
this night because that didn't make no
sense bro
[Applause]
look at the building that was just that
was special that was when i was like i'm
glad my dog is back home where he's
supposed to be this is
this was the this is how it was supposed
to be
none of them other things looked right
all right let's let's move on to the
next clip
let's see what the timer is
that's crazy crazy sick
same thing huh the same thing let me
tell you let me tell you
now that's different yeah this is this
is
you know we all know dwayne's a champion
but this was one shot
and he fell on two people
any games he probably wasn't
you know this whole quiet we all got
watching this
that's one of the best defenders in the
league that he that he'd taken with the
bb
and then he got one a defensive player
here coming to help which he
fouled him on that play that was a foul
that was an
8.3 look at this he gets knocked all the
way down
that's straight up give me the ball i
could push just give me the ball
i i'm a bad mofo and ain't nothing
nobody can do cause you see he
fall like he [ __ ] get open you know
sometimes in those positions
some people should might not fight that
hard to get the ball he wanted
everything
that's like you know he had great
offensive play he definitely worked to
get open
yeah some people don't get denied i got
to go harden because
he worked to get open drove right he's a
lefty drove right against two of the
best defenders
and money and i like the fact that
he knew that shot was going in we look
at his balance on that shot
he was straight up definitely down
n1 yeah
that was tough that was tough so i've
never seen anyone get their game-winning
shot
blocked and then recover within the same
like three seconds
and re-shoot it and make it especially
without one leg
and hand the head the wherewithal to
keep the one leg behind the line
listen listen listen eway himself
wouldn't pick that play over the heart
and play
i gotta go with the hard play and let me
tell i'm serious let me tell you why
because
i feel like listen i feel like d-way
himself
would tell you that that was like semi a
lucky shot after he pumped faith in
color he did
you know that was like i'm blessed i'm
blessed you know what i'm saying
the hardened shot ain't unlucky about
this
this is give me the ball and watch this
like
that's staring down klay thompson one of
the best defenders in the nba
one-on-one i'm gonna be thank you at the
end when it when the
defensive player here come to help i'm
gonna absorb this contact and it's
really the end one and i'm about to
drain this thing and the best part about
it all is like
his team makes more hype than him he get
up like here
like that's what i do like watch how he
get up watch his reaction pj run up
i would want to do this these are the
ones you practice for
like these type of shots d1 the d-wave
one was like
that was just experience like you know
your foot is behind the line
you know pick it up that's just pure fed
experience but
when you're a kid you practicing you
want to hit a shot like this
this is a be real this is this is this
is like
this is some kobe type stuff this is
what we watch kobe do
you catch the ball and straight up blah
blah blah and kill you like this is what
he just did right there carter
is this category heads down he gets the
w which puts him in the lead
in the one-on-one category two to one
party's up
i got him right now he gets you know
he got a shot to get back you got a shot
next category is
buzzer beater you know exactly what that
means both of these guys have a ton of
them so let's start with you wait and
see what we got here
no
you all know the worst part of this i
was on this team i was on this phoenix
team
this is a national tv game on espn and
this was year we had the best break in
the league and we were
we were rolling and we came in here and
came in like it was a snooze and we was
getting popped if you look at the score
they were they was up big at this point
like now we fought back and got back in
the game but like now like that's me
standing right there that's me standing
right down to the left
washington
[Music]
just did fit like i'm missing d-wade i'm
missing d-wade on the court watching
these clips
listen i'm telling you guys i appreciate
the key it's crazy
you don't know how good he is to get
going you don't realize it especially
when you're playing you don't even
realize it
let's go to the next clip let's go to
hardin hart putting the team on his back
in this next clip this is the game three
winner
in a battle from 2016. oh my god
how do you guard
[Music]
this guy's straight up
balance killer against iguodala
that's pretty impressive you always
dream of a big shot against the best
defender
but if i gotta pick the best i hate to
do this i i thought i was coming into
this thing bias y'all that y'all didn't
trick me y'all got me going in this
train and going against my brother he
gonna get in my he gonna be on me when
he see this damn video but
i gotta go hard bro like first of all
like you said look at look what's going
on the warriors lead the series
2-0 right now this is the game-winner to
give them
hope you know if they lose that game
right run
and go 3-0 it's all kirk that game
winner right there that he did put them
up
he made the series 2-1 in favor of the
words instead of 3-0
so but then again you bring the other
stand part into it
like you said you dream of going up
against the best defender and iggy the
best defender in the clutch defender and
all this and he walked with them took
him to the hall spin step back
leave it and then walk off like a bad
man
it's no heave it's not like this is
straight kill mode
me versus you they weren't supposed to
have a chance to score before the court
ended my mandy we pumped that ball
blocked it didn't even look around to
his left door right he said i'm gonna do
this myself
chucked it up i find the hat from behind
the hat
we gotta talk about the fact that he
shot it he didn't just lob it up for
luck like this man shot the ball i
didn't know
this one just sick it's like defense
and offense you know within two seconds
it was just from beyond from the heat
symbol on the other side
man anyway y'all got me on the outside
looking in and i'm going against my
brother
maybe i feel this way because this play
was against us and i
probably just don't like it somewhere on
the deep down inside me so
you know whatever this last category
is called the wow factor i
know y'all remember this play i know
y'all remember this clip
yeah this and i see this this right here
this is insane for the ball of
my house yes yes this right here
is really if you look i don't even know
what y'all about to put up here for
heart but it
it it's good night get that i remember
this i caught this boy after this guy
really cleared on him whatever
was actually food right he looked at him
stood up on top
like oh my goodness this was this was
one for the record books right here
this is crazy right i'm telling you the
one-legged runner
for three you gotta have touched
[Applause]
we get last shot or we going overtime we
win or we're going overtime that's what
they coach telling them
and that man took the ball and won the
game that was the last
outcome that they think and they like
cool we either gonna get a shot we're
gonna win or we're going over time we're
gonna get ready to play
that man wrenching the whole system
though that was crazy yeah
yeah every category should be different
but because
they're so dirty these guys play so
disrespectful the stuff they do you just
don't do
you gotta laugh because that is so sick
all right
all right let's move to hardin this is
it y'all this is for this is this is to
see who is the one-on-one champion
what's the defender on skates oh no
yes i remember this right here this is
tough
i
it's time for us to put our votes in
letter
i'm going to start with you i'm putting
you in the hot streak
who are you going with win it all
all right here we go here we go so all
right dude when he comes help
steals it and keeps
[Music]
oh man look at this guy oh my goodness
i gotta go with d-wade
this is crazy i'm gonna go with my
man-hearted and why not because
look at what this man definitely can do
all the time he is a clutch player
ice cold you know
ice in his veins this man it doesn't
make sense he's vicious
kim it's all new who's winning this
thing
hey listen this is why i love this show
because i can make this vote
and i don't have to feel bad about it
because it's not disrespecting either
either of these great talents i still
got love for both of them in their game
and
everything but listen man the d-wade
play
this is double overtime
he's on defense man took the ball
and then went down inside our one leg
bruh
one leg like he's not but look how you
come he come on help side
give me that and then let me go win the
game
look at that one leg do you understand
the type of balancing
everything you got to have together when
you got all that momentum it's the
clutch moment it's all these different
things that go into that that man
cashed out no real no nothing and you
put the cherry on top because they got
the
l heat jersey on it was latino night in
the business
and it's double overtime and i told you
already the whole
city of chicago watching that's live on
location wg and everybody said he know
his whole family tree back home watching
and then he said this my house though
that's it
game mode d wade i got you bro
two great players two great players
it's tough it was hard throughout the
entire thing it was it was a tough
battle
they both went head to head they both
were disrespectful
they both had the wow factor but in the
end my man d
wade came out strong as a one-on-one
champion can we clap it up for my man d
wade congratulations to my guy
hey man hey this is a lot of fun matters
[Music]
we can't do the show without you so
thank you as always for joining us
and everyone viewing thank you for
watching until the next episode
d wade the new champion 101.
this episode was brought to you by state
farm like a good neighbor
state farm is there